-Welcome back!
-Thank you. It's been a while.
-And it has been a while.
And I really appreciate this.
You took a red-eye today, yes?
Or, last night.
-Yes.
-But for a good reason.
You're in L.A. to give an award.
-To give a tribute --
a tribute because George Clooney
got the A.F.I.
Lifetime Achievement award.
-Which is a fantastic award.
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
-I would imagine...
-It was pretty great.
-...versus most award shows,
that night is so much better.
-It's so much better.
-Yeah.
-First of all, everyone's there
'cause they want to be.
-Yeah.
-And everyone speak --
Everyone's chosen to give him
a tribute because they love him.
-Yeah.
-And so their words are for real
rather than some fake bull.
-Yeah.
-You know,
and everyone's nodding.
It truly was
very emotional and beautiful.
And his dad spoke,
and Amal spoke.
And I got a little teary
because, you know,
honestly, I owe my career
to George Clooney.
-Yeah.
-I do.
-I mean, he -- but, wouldn't you
say that he owes as much to you?
I mean, you guys --
-No, no, no, let me explain.
-Okay.
-I seriously owe my career
to George Clooney.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Because my character died
in the pilot of "ER."
-Oh, wow.
-And I was about to sign on
to a not-very-good sitcom,
'cause I came back to New York,
I needed a job.
And he called me
out of the blue,
kind of put his neck out
on the line for me and said,
"I overheard that your character
tested well, and if I were you,
I wouldn't take another job,
because I think
they're gonna
bring you back to life."
-Oh, that's amazing.
-Yeah.
-So, really, in the end,
that was the greatest save
he ever did in the E.R.
is he brought you back to life.
-He brought me back to life.
-Yeah. I mean, that is --
I mean, for all of them...
-He did.
-Well, I always remember,
it was --
You know, for me, I always
thought it was really touching,
your last episode,
that George came back
and did that great cameo.
And I thought, like,
"Oh, these are two people
who obviously really
care about each other
for something
like that to happen."
-That was --
We did all of that in secret.
-Well, I remember being
blown away that he would --
I mean, it was a great reveal.
-No, I mean,
not even the cast and crew knew.
-Oh, my God.
-And, when I heard --
-Did you just bring in the tape,
and you're like,
"Put this in the episode,
you guys"?
"I shot something on it
with a side crew."
-They actually --
They flew us to Seattle.
But they flew George
on the Warner Bros. private jet.
I took commercial.
-Right.